when you go back into the the history of
the seven kingdoms the history of
westeros
you find they're the roots of the
religions and how each one has come to
be
the seven have never answered my prayers
perhaps the old gods will
originally westeros was the domain of
various non-human races the children of
the forest
and they worshipped the old gods the
gods of the trees the gods of the
rocks stones of the mountains of the
streams
who had no names there were no churches
or temples and there was no
priesthood and the symbol of them was
the weirwood trees
these white trees with red leaves
and red sap so when you cut them with a
knife they would seem to bleed
they became the center of the religion
of the old gods
then at a certain point the first men
came to westeros the first human beings
crossing from essos the first men
accepted the gods of the children of the
forest in the north where
the lords are still descended from the
first men the the old gods are still
worshiped
the starks follow the old religion in
winterfell they have
the godswood all these years and i still
feel like an outsider when i come here
you're not an outsider i wonder if the
old gods agree
it's your gods with all the rules the
starks keep the old god
they also have a little sept there for
the seven because lady catelyn having
come up from the south
is a worshiper of the seven for many
centuries it's been the dominant
religion it was a religion that was
brought over hundreds of years ago by
the andals the entire religion is built
around the symbology of seven the
symbol of it is the seven pointed star
seven blessings on you your christ
the seven gods are seen to be seven
facets of
the one god there are three male aspects
the
the father the warrior and the smith
there are three female aspects the
mother
the maiden and the crone and there's the
seventh aspect the stranger who is
neither male nor female who represents
the unknown represents death each of the
seven aspects of
the god has certain things that they're
of course in charge of you pray to the
mother for healthy childbirth you pray
to warrior if you want strength in
battle
may the seven guide her and protect her
on her journey
may the mother give her health may the
crone give her wisdom
they have both male and female priests
who are called septons or septas
they also have the equivalent of monks
and friars who are various orders
one of the most prominent are the silent
sisters who
take a vow of silence and are in charge
of dealing with the bodies of the
of the slain what's dead i never said
they never die
on the iron islands they follow their
own gods
the ironborn worship the drowned god
it's a tough place and it's a tough
religion
they're seafarers and their god lives
under the sea
and they believe that's where their
heaven is they don't fear dying at sea
at all
and they don't fear drowning they drown
they will be taken down to the
halls of the drowned god under the sea
where mermaids will wait on them
and they will feast and frolic for for
all time for worships as a drowned god
the
holy water is sea water when you're
young
almost as a baptismal right they
actually drown you
and then you're brought back to life
theon had that done to him when he was
young
just like his brothers did and his his
father and his father's father
when he comes back to the islands having
been away for so long they're worried
whether he's still
an ironborn i think when baylen first
sees his son
he doesn't trust theon does he
honor our god or has he been converted
to
these religions of the green lands my
fears have come true
the starks have made you theirs my blood
is salt and iron
his father insists that he be blessed
with seawater once again
theon of the house greyjoy you would
this day consecrate your faith to the
drowned god
i would that baptism is being
reinitiated into the faith of his
forefathers
let theon your servant be born again
from the sea as you were
he's saying i'm not a stark and he's
gone back to the drowned god
what is dead may never die what is dead
may never die
the faith of the lord of light has been
unable to get a foothold in westeros
until recently
she's a foreigner preaching a foreign
religion the religion
of the lord of light is melisandre's
faith for the night is dark and
full of terrors melisandre is
charismatic priestess from another
country
she has powers granted to her by some
divine force she's been there for a
while
and she's been trying to convert stannis
first you must give yourself to the lord
of life
i've said the word it's very focused on
on prophecy
and on ecstatic visions that are
received
through communion with the flames i have
seen the path to victory in the flames
she believes stannis to be
a savior figure there's only one true
god and that's
the lord of light so all these other
gods that the people of westeros are
worshiping
the drown god on the iron islands the
seven
the old gods they're demons therefore
in melisandre's world view they have to
be destroyed it's a
very black and white view of the
universe
which rubs many people the wrong way
all you men were named in the light of
the seven
this is how you treat the gods of your
fathers
part of accepting the faith of
the lord of light is you know putting
all of the gods aside
ultimately stannis yields to
melisandre's entreaties and puts the
seven wooden likenesses of the gods of
faith to the fire so burning the idols
is getting rid of the seven and paving
way for
the new god and of course it's not just
any guy it's a god of fire
he is discarding the gods that he has
worshipped since childhood and accepting
the red god and giving himself to the
lord of light
and in return melisandre sees that the
lord of light gives him
a token your sword awaits you of his
role as the prince that was promised by
ancient prophecy
and that's the sword lightbringer he's
able to use the religion
as a means to an end and of course that
end is gaining the iron throne
the iron throne is mine by right